Đây là những hình hình hình về báo chi kinh mạng trong cao trào kinh mạng thân tắm nè mùng nghìn chính trọng bốm lắm.
Được trưng bay tại bảo tăng lịch sự cuối xa.
Các tờ báo này đã trở thành một mặt trận đấu trang sắc bánh,
đã bự kịch thời yêu cầu của cán bộ đàn viên và các hội viên cứu quốc trong cao trào đấu trình kinh mạng.
Trong đó, tờ báo viên năng độc lập, đều có phần to lợn vào việc tuyên chuyển,
xây dịch lực lượng kinh mạng, trình bị khởi giết sành trình quyền,
trúc thời gian mạng thân tắm nè mùng nghìn chính trọng bốm lắm.
Báo biến năng gia đình để đường trường nước,
hình hãy tháng tháng 1, đưa 1, đường 1, đánh tụi của người trực tiếp lệnh đạo phong trọng bánh bệnh năng.
Báo tại cao bằng phía lệnh tụi của người phó đã án sáng lập,
và trực tiếp phủ trách tờ báo viên tâm độc lập.
Chính là cơ quan tinh truyền của mặt trận viên mình,
tại thình các bạn lội dung của những tài tâm trên báo viên năng độc lập,
lường tháng gọi, để hiểu dễ nhớ phù hợp với trình độ của quần trống như thế dân.
Nhàm cứu hợp tàn thế dân, đoàn kết, thăm ra vào bảo vệnh trận viện cho tổng về dễ thân cáa
hôm nay chỉ trăm mối mắm.
Báo đồng tương truyền là một mặt trận quan trọng cho các bạn tính tắm nè mùng nghiên chính trọng bốm lắm.
Và chuyên đơn chính là bố ký chủ lực của mặt trận ấy,
những lời hiểu chiều thông dột các tận lắm như dân lượng nè,
lần đầu chỉ đổ thống chỉ hạch đều được thể hiện qua các chuyên đơn.
Cái là đi đường, mình tình thấy có ai đứng, mình đường xe,
là người ta giữ lửa thay hông ra.
Cái chuyên đơn và nộ giúp chuyên đơn thì đều kêu gọi là phù hộ bị chính phố nè.
Chính phố của phù chi Minh và kêu gọi người rất là mang kế sức của chúng ta.
Để tựa hợp của chúng ta.
Cái là mang sức ta để từ qua cái nước là cái chuyên đơn,
hãy hơi gọi cái hầm kêu nho.
Chọn người dân lời lẽ phố nó rất là mổ mặt.
Những hiện vật lịch sử dụng anh thích mặt thẳng tắm,
còn là những kỳ vật mà thân nhân các chiên dịch mặt và lưu dữ.
Ngay trung đêm 18 năm, những chiên trọng bốm lắm.
Thường vô sửu ý, cuối đỉnh thành lập 8 dân tích mặt bố.
Nhà kích mặt, mũi thân, đường dão dự vụ phó chủ tịch.
Bất gành chiếm vụ khắp sai trong tổng thường nghĩ ở người chiến tắm
nếu mùi nhìn chiếc chẳng bố mắm tạy hà nội.
Giò tăng giả vũ lăng ăn chục, được tạng lại cho ra định nhà kinh mặt nguyễn xuy thân.
Đãnh trở thành báo vật thiliên của ra định.
Đến khi mặt ở mắt thì tụi tồi nôn lần dữ cái kỳ vật kinh bất gái này
như là một thương lựa, thương lựa trong ra định mặt sồn nó chỉ là một kinh bất gái.
Rất lập tụi.
Những hiện vật lịch sử được trưng bay chân trọng tại bảo thang
hay những kỳ vật đừng người thân của các chiến sĩ dịn dữ
như báo vật ra định.
Điều là mình chiến trưng một thử vật sông của sân tạo.
Chúng xuất mỗi người ra thông ngay nhận thức đúng đáng về lịch sử dân tạo.
Từ đó, bây chân trọng dịn dữ, và phát huy thân sự vang trở lại trong thử dải mới.